derniers moments de calme avant le
service bernadette 88 ans termine de
préparer la salle elle a tenu ce
restaurant avec son mari pendant 40 ans
je faisais la cuisine je faisais tout
allait bien être travaillés en avait
pour toujours du personnel élus
personnalités cher à l'autre on faisait
on se levait pas midi pour faire le les
repas en salle est à 10 heures du matin
tout préparés parce qu'on avait beaucoup
d'ouvriers qui menait maintenant après
sa retraite personne n'a voulu succéder
à bernadette l'établissement ouvre
uniquement tous les trois ans pour
conserver la licence iv en cuisine en
salle ou derrière le bar toute la
famille s'y met un rendez vous coquin
anciens habitués ne peut manquer on est
là il ya 30 ans 44 45 hommes s'étaient
ouverts cdc des souvenirs c'est un
petite pointe de nostalgie
nous voilà et on se rappelle des bons
moments parce que c'est toujours les
mêmes qui viennent
alors nous on sait marier ici en 1975 on
a fait le repas ici les clients viennent
pour l'ambiance mais aussi pour les
miches ont une spécialité du village à
base de comptes et de farine et d'eau on
dit que ceux de jean luc nos fils de
bernadette sont particulièrement bons
mais il a choisi de les préparer loin de
la cuisine familiale
moi j'ai la chance de travailler
l'étranger en antarctique et j'en fais
pour les scientifiques
et puis les légendes passage les
journalistes ou autres vip du viennois
midi et soir
le restaurant est complet et presque
chaque client a une anecdote à raconter
des copains montée d'oyonnax venait de
la rive-nord et on mangeait à 3,4 on a
une table réservée
toutes les semaines
parce que la cuisine était bonne elle
était très sympa à la fin du service
bernadette prend enfin le temps de
saluer les habitués certains reviendront
plusieurs fois avant dimanche jour de
fermeture pour trois ans